And the ninth most common question asked
by the non-Muslim regarding Islam, why
does Islam not permit the non-Muslims to
enter Makkah? If Islam is a universal
religion for all the human beings, why
does it not allow the Muslims to enter
Makkah? The reply to this question is
that in every country there is a
cantonement area. Cantonement area means
that area which every citizen of that
country cannot enter. Only those who are
involved in military or involved with
the defense of the country allowed. You
cannot say that I am a Nigerian so I
will enter the cantonement area. No,
only those who are involved or I am a
Kenyan and I want to enter the
cantonement area. No, only those Kenyan
which are involved in the military or
involved with the defense of the country
can go. It's a cantonement area, a
secured place. So similarly the
cantononement area for the Muslims is
the Makkah. Allah says in the Quran in
surah TBA chapter number N verse number
28 that from this day do not allow the
non-Muslims the polytheist to enter the
Makkah enter the haram. So there's a
verse in the Quran in surah taba chapter
9:28 saying that from this day from now
onward do not allow the non-Muslims do
not allow and the polytheist to enter
must the haram because in Islam Makkah
is a cantonement area only those who are
Muslims who believe in Allah and his
messenger those who are ready to die for
this religion are allowed to enter
Makkah others aren't though Islam is for
the whole world for all the human beings
they're most welcome but unless you do
not testify unless you don't believe in
one God and the messenger and unless
you're not willing to die for your
religion you cannot enter this cabba the
second reason whenever you enter a
country there is a requirement of visa
like when you go to USA one of the most
difficult requirements they'll ask you
so many questions before you get the
visa when I went to UA When I went to
Singapore, it mentioned there death to
drug traffickers. That means
if you're dealing in drug, there'll be
death penalty. You cannot say no death
penalty such a barbaric law. If you want
to enter Singapore, you have to sign
that if you are caught with drug death
penalty. You have no option otherwise
you don't get visa. Just similarly the
visa for entering Makkah is that any
human being who says with his lips
Muhammad Abdulah that I bear witness
that there's no god but Allah and I bear
witness that prophet Muhammad is the
messenger and servant of Allah. Anyone
who says this he will fulfill one of the
major criteria to get visa. If you don't
say this you cannot get visa. So that is
a requirement of visa to enter Makkah.
So this was a reply to the ninth most
common question.